nous en direct avec taoufik jebali
maître de conférences en civilisation
américaine à l'université de caen auteur
de minorités et pouvoir dans les pays
anglophones aux éditions l'harmattan
bonsoir toufik chebani merci d'être avec
nous est ce que ce constat un chiffre
édifiant concernant la population
afro-américaine et ces chiffres voilà
qui prouve qu'ils sont plus touchés par
le virus est ce que ça vous surprend
en fait ça me surprend ça ne me surprend
pas du tout du tout vu la situation déjà
dans laquelle se trouvaient les
afro-américains bien avant la pandémie
qui sévit partout dans le monde
donc en fait le problème des
afro-américains est un problème tout à
fait en sciences et en relation
essentiellement avec le soin et les
soins médicaux alors c'est
essentiellement des causes sociales
l'invité précédent qu'on entendait
enregistré en tout cas parler de pénurie
de tests qui concernaient principalement
cette population pour quelles raisons
tout d'abord c'est lié en premier lieu
je crois au système de soin aux etats
unis c'est un système à deux vitesses
ceux qui ont les moyens d'avoir une
assurance ils ont accès à des soins de
qualité
ceux qui sont pauvres il ya un programme
qui s'appelle medicaid
mais qui donne accès à un minimum de
soins et ceux qui n'ont pas d'assurance
qu'ils ne sont qui ne sont ni pauvre ni
assez je dirais pauvres pour avoir accès
à ce programme fédéral medicaid
ils ne sont pas assez riches pour se
payer une assurance privée
donc il se trouve entre les deux est
donc et ne bénéficient pas de d'une
couverture médicale ces gens là ils sont
essentiellement des minorités et je
dirais des afro américains
donc il y à la question elle est très
très profondes liées au système médical
américain
il a énormément de déficiences dans ce
système il ya énormément de problèmes
obama avec sa réforme de 2010 n'a pas pu
complètement résoudre le problème il ya
une résistance à la fois des lobbys une
résistance d'une partie de la population
une partie privilégiée et du coup on se
trouve avec un système qui de toute
façon ne regarde que ceux qui ont de
l'argent
du coup évidemment les afro-américains
qui représente grosso modo 30 pour 13%
de la population
il représente donc à peu près 30% des
pauvres ça veut dire que c'est une
population extrêmement pauvre par
rapport à d'autres communautés et du
coup elle se trouve à la marge de la
société à la marge
bien entendu du système médical
américain donc il y à une question
d'argent qui est une question centrale
dans le système médical américain et les
noirs américains les afro américains se
trouvent complètement marginalisé par
rapport à ce système qui de toute façon
est un système du jeu plus un hôpital
américain et les larmes
essentiellement pour faire pour se faire
de l'argent donc il y a un nom et ne
machines à sous qui est qui est là et
pas un hôpital qui est au service de la
population américaine
alors on parle beaucoup des américains
qu'on est il des hispaniques sachant
passage que c'est vrai qu'on parle de
ses minorités
ça veut dire que les états unis dispose
de statistiques ethniques
effectivement tout d'abord par rapport à
ce virus le coronavirus il n'y a pas de
statistiques nationales et ça a été dit
dans votre reportage
donc il n'ya pas de statistiques
fédérales jusqu'à maintenant il ya des
appels à ce que on arrive à avoir une
vue d'ensemble sur ce problème
on a des chiffres on a dit statistique
sur le plan de l'état ont sur le temps
autour de haut sur le plan de la ville
ou de comptes et donc quelque part
c'est c'est un problème extrêmement
sérieux
ça veut dire que le gouvernement fédéral
n'a même pas vraiment de trace n'a pas
de chiffre crédible sur la question des
minorités par rapport aux espagnols
effectivement et ce en plus proche sur
le plan sociologique sur le plan social
et je dis ici je dirais plutôt par
rapport à des critères par rapport à des
indicateurs économiques ils sont plus
proches de la communauté noire que de la
communauté blanche
il se trouve je lirai entre les deux
mais ils sont par rapport à ces chiffres
là les chiffres par rapport aux
hispaniques ne sont pas aussi dramatique
pour que pour la communauté afro
américaine
donc ils sont défavorisés par le système
est encore plus quand il s'agit de
quelques millions d'hispaniques qui se
trouvent en dehors pratiquement de
l'administration américaine des
statistiques de l'administration
américaine en parle de 12 millions
grosso modo de 12 millions de
clandestins essentiellement donc
d'espagne et des hispaniques
donc ces gens là ils sont en effet à la
marge de la société
mais il faut savoir aussi que les
espagnols représentent
c'est la deuxième c'est la plus grande
minorité américaine 6 2 16% de la
population
cette population elle souffre et elle va
souffrir énormément je dirais pas
peut-être pas autant que les afro
américains
mais le problème est sérieux et sans
fortement impactés par ce problème et je
dirais que l'art avec les afro
américains seront constitués vraiment
les laissés pour compte de ce système à
la fois médicale et je serai
certainement les premières victimes de
ce virus et de cette pandémie
taoufik jebali clairement est ce que
vous craignez particulièrement aux
etats-unis une catastrophe sanitaire
sans précédent
sachant vous l'avez expliqué un que le
système de santé
est ce qu'il est un plusieurs dizaines
de milliers
de dollars pour malades du coït sachant
qu'ils n'ont pas tous une couverture et
qu'il ya énormément de chômage est ce
qu'il ya une énorme inquiétude à avoir
pour les états unis
plus qu'ailleurs moi je pense que pour
les états unis ça va être un sérieux
problème
tout d'abord il ya une question
politique derrière tout ça c'est que
trempe au début n'a pas pris les choses
au sérieux et donc il a fallu vraiment
que la catastrophe touche des états
comme new york ou la californie pour que
donald femme se réveille et que je
dirais et donc pour qu'ils prennent les
choses au sérieux et qu'il intervienne
pratiquement aujourd'hui on le voit tous
les jours devant les caméras de la
télévision pour expliquer sa démarche
donc il y à une ex une inquiétude réelle
on arrive à des chiffres mais un
hallucinant sur cette catastrophe
je pense qu'on n'est pas encore je
dirais excusez moi l'expression sorti de
l'auberge
il va y avoir énormément de dégâts c'est
ce n'est juste que ce n'est que le début
et que le problème va toucher d'autres
endroits que new york est que l'amérique
elle est complètement démunis la une les
photos les partager par manal de soi par
l'état fédéré soit par l'état fédéral
mais il va y avoir pas mal de problèmes
et je personnellement je m'inquiète
énormément de du problème delà de ce qui
va se passer aux états unis les états
unis vu le système politique vue là la
tradition où je dirais vu le système
médical aux états unis
je crains le pire pour les américains et
surtout évidemment par un euro je parle
ici par rapport aux pauvres et il va il
ya plus de 32 40 millions de pauvres par
rapport aux afro-américains par rapport
aux minorités
la vache ça va avoir énormément de
dégâts
merci beaucoup taoufik djebel je vous en
prie